thank you
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight I'll be as well get uncensored
as the sussex's demand apologies but
then use Jeremy Clarkson's wholesome
apology to throw back in his face and
vilify and humiliating my answer
question is redemption now impossible in
the age of woke cancer culture
until you're being canceled he was
attacked abused and harassed for a crime
of rape he never committed Jordan
trengrove's life was ruined when he was
falsely accused by an evil fantasist who
was now herself being put behind bars
tonight he tells his extraordinary and
disturbing story
live
is Piers Morgan uncensored well good
evening London welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored uh well Harry and Megan uh
sorry to keep banging on about them but
they keep banging on about everybody
else don't they so we have no choice
until they get exhausted and we all get
exhausted and we can all move on but for
now they remain in the position that
they are demanding an apology from the
royal family for all the filth that
they've thrown at the royal family in
the last two years
but why should the royal family
apologize when you consider what's
happened with Jeremy Clarkson now
Clarkson wrote what he has admitted was
a stupid and inflammatory newspaper
column but overstepped the mark the
outrage was predictable and it was
frankly Justified as he now concedes but
he apologized on Twitter said he got it
completely wrong then on Christmas day
he wrote directly to Prince Harry on
Christmas day think about that and
yesterday he issued a sprawling shame
face self-immolation of a public apology
about as groveling as it could be I
really am sorry he pleaded all the way
from the balls of my feet to the
follicles of my head this is me putting
my hands up into Mia culpa with belzon
it doesn't get more fulsome frankly than
what he posted on Instagram and coming
from Clarkson it would probably rather
shoot himself and be like that normally
it carried even more weight
but it wasn't enough
for Harry and Megan
and he took me back actually to when I
was asked to apologize to Meghan Markle
for doubting her word on Good Morning
Britain and one of the reasons I refused
was why would I apologize a for
something I believe I.E she lies and
secondly if I did Apologize what do you
think would happen
anyway even if I pretended that I was
sorry they wouldn't accept it she
wouldn't accept it she'd just use that
as an excuse to go even harder that's
what they do they they're the victims
always perennial victims
so I refuse and I left and I'm very
happy about that because I wouldn't be
here doing my show if I hadn't done that
but Clarkson is now in a similar
position looking like he may possibly
lose a lucrative and highly popular
series of shows on Amazon Prime perhaps
even Who Wants To Be A Millionaire at
ITV and you might have your own view
either way about whether Clarkson should
be canceled in this way I don't think it
he should be I don't think that
punishment fits the crime of a stupid
joke in a column
but let's go back again to the apology
they were desperate for an apology from
Clarkston simply so they could reject it
they could have accepted it noted it
people ignored it but instead they
reveled in it pouring fuel on the Flames
of his humiliation without as they
lashed him in a statement for writing
articles that spread hate rhetoric
dangerous conspiracy theories a misogyny
it's clear this is not an isolated
incident shared and haste they said but
rather a series of Articles shared in
hate got the dripping pomposity of that
statement
and the disingenuousness of it
Harry let us remind ourselves it's just
literally just published a best-selling
416 page book which is effectively a
series of Articles shared in hate and
when it comes to misogyny he like his
wife identifies Arch feminists and yet
here he is and we've gone to the audio
book to put it in his own words
describing the disabled matron that he
mocked at school
unlike the other matrons Pat wasn't hot
Pat was called Power was small walking
was hard stairs were torture she descend
backwards glacially
often we stand on the landing below her
doing antique dances making faces
do I need to say which boy did this with
the most enthusiasm we went on mocking
her as she came down the stairs the
reward was worth the risk
for me the reward wasn't tormenting poor
Pat but making my mates laugh
where's Pat's apology
and what about the first woman he slept
with
suspected he was referring to my recent
loss of virginity in glorious episode
with an older woman she liked horses
quite a lot and treated me not unlike a
young stallion quick ride after which
she'd smacked my rump and sent me off to
graze among the many things about it
that were wrong it happened in a grassy
field behind a busy Pub
there'll be a way to talk about this
older woman a private citizen who's now
the subject of global mockery
who is that woman does he care about the
way he talked about her
it's not exactly chivalrous is it to
reveal stuff like that in a book that's
been read by millions around the world
but it's her apology
and how about the female newspaper
editor the Harry really didn't like
who the hell is this editor
loathsome toad I gathered everyone who
knew her was in full agreement that she
was an infected posture on the ass of
humanity plus excuse for a journalist an
infected pustule on the ass of humanity
what does that say with
being nice to women
being supportive of a woman being a
feminist
where's the apology for that female
newspaper editor
is it going to be one for that blatant
misogyny and what about Camilla the
queen console his own stepmother
she was the villain
she was the third person in the marriage
she needed to rehabilitate Her Image in
a funny way I even wanted Camilla to be
happy maybe she'd be less dangerous if
she was happy
his own stepmother the love of his
father's life our Queen to be she'll be
coronated too
a dangerous villain
where's Camilla's apology
for that hateful rhetoric
it's in my point here
if anyone should be groveling for
forgiveness and issuing apologies isn't
it Harry and Megan
for selling all the family secrets to
the highest bidders so allowing the
Royals to be smeared as racist and then
say oh we didn't mean to do that two
years later for allowing Britain to be
cast as a bigoted hell hole
but they won't ever apologize for any of
it because they're Hypocrites they're
professional victims who wallow for a
living and there's no point apologizing
to professional victims I knew that when
I was asked to apologize to Meghan
Markle two years ago why would you when
they do what they did to Jeremy Clarkson
it's not about forgiveness anyway it's
about scoring points to humiliate their
enemies to reinforce that victimhood
and they'll always come back for more
because that's the currency of where
they now find themselves well joining me
out of the debate all there's this black
lives matter activist Iman Ayden talk TV
presenter Richard Tice and talk to the
presenter Trisha Goddard who is in the
stage well welcome to all of you Trisha
here's my central problem with this and
you and I have disagreed about a lot of
uh this this whole story from start to
finish in fact you're on the Good
Morning Britain episode that led to me
departing but on the central charge I
make of rank hypocrisy when you hear
those excerpts from Harry's book in his
own words particularly I would argue the
way he mocks this poor matron and we
don't know what's happened to her that
is blatant misogyny the way he talks
about her in that book
who is he to really be demanding
apologies for misogyny from others
without offering one himself to those
that he's been misogynist towards
I think as Harry rightfully said in
Camilla's words and Camilla you know the
uh Queen consort has been very strong on
this it was more the violence uh that
that Jeremy Clarkson involved in that
you know Game of Thrones clumsy Game of
Thrones quote-unquote joke
um and I think it was more the violence
that they were talking about
misogyny I don't know if it is if you
put something into context about all the
boys mocking somebody who was disabled
which I I don't agree with at all but
it's the actual violence of putting it
out there and the way in which it was
done uh without a and naming the person
actually naming the person and the
person already having said that
um they've suffered as a result of
hatred in the Press they've had death
threats and so on so first of all I was
thinking that and I don't think we
should lose the site that it's not the
sussexes
um perhaps putting Jeremy Clarkson out
of a job that's got nothing to do with
whether he apologizes or not you and I
appears no and Richard Tice would know
as well for our employers we sign a
contract that we won't bring our
companies in to disrepute now if our
companies if our employers decide that
we've actually done that then you know
it's up to them whether they fire us or
not okay but on the on the on the fact
that they have simply refused to accept
what is clearly a very long and fulsome
apology this is what everyone has been
demanding well actually it is if you
read the whole thing you post on
Instagram yeah I did absolutely I did
well you don't think I'm comfortable
with it no I I wasn't it did seem a
little bit you know from the balls of my
feet and what have you it did and I
don't understand peace maybe you you
know better than I obviously when it
said private and confidential how do we
know the contents you know I I just
don't get it it did seem the fact that
it was so publicly done
um surely the way of do to do it would
have been to quietly go about it and
what have you but I'm talking about
sorry we are talking about an apology
made to the two least private people in
the world right now people who knows
every private conversation
to say that well well two wrongs don't
make a right but I I just found were
they right
we can all choose to what we want to do
with it well were they right
did he sit well with it I I yeah we live
in this cancel cultural world where
everyone screams and Jeremy Clarkson
must never be allowed to you know walk
again in public or get a job but but who
said that I I believe it if you do
repent if you do admit what you did was
completely wrong particularly if it's a
dumb joke in a newspaper column right
which it was it was a stupid thing you
shouldn't have done it no one's
defending what he wrote right so let's
just agree on that but would you then
make a wholesome public apology which
goes against everything Clarkson stands
for by the way
for the people who then receive it to
literally not just refuse to accept it
but go on the attack seems to me utterly
graceless
I don't think that for me personally I
don't think they were on the attack I
thought they were stating the obvious
about you know but
um I I will have to disagree about the
fulsome apology you might see it as that
maybe you're a mate of his uh from the
reading I'm not to be honest let me
clarify that as I said on last night's
show I have a scar on my head from where
he punched me in the head so we're not
exactly the best buddies I do get on I
have to be friends get on okay with him
now in the sense in a bit like uh you
know two I guess two porcupines prowling
around each other when we leave at
parties
um it's a bit like that so we're not
exactly easy so I don't you know I've
got no reason to defend him and I'm not
defending by the way remotely what he
wrote the moment I read it I thought it
was completely wrong my only question
I've come to the other panelists now
um I mean it seems to me if we if we
don't accept somebody literally as he
puts it from you know balls to head it's
falling on his feet basically begging
for forgiveness admitting he should
never have done it was a total disgrace
etc etc
let me not find it somehow in our hearts
to say okay
okay we get it
you know you completely screwed up but
we accept the apology one million
percent for two reasons why yes I do I
don't want to make a habit of it but
I'll be honest yes I do agree with you
so first forgiveness shows growth and
maturity that's just obvious second this
is also about reputation management it's
almost as if they're not being strategic
I have to admit I mean on a reputation
management perspective they would look a
lot better if they did accept the
apology first they would keep the upper
hand look good doing it and then again
they would be able to lead the way and
they wouldn't look super critical when
it comes to them actually expecting
enough energy from royal family so from
a strategic standpoint I think they
failed a business well I think it's a
really that's a really good point
Richard because if you're the royal
family you've seen this demand you know
there can only be a reproach more says
the guy who's just trashed them in every
possible media space if they basically
apologize for what they did to me and my
wife but then you see somebody make an
abject apology and they just throw it
straight back in his face the whole
thing's unbelievable mean they had the
chance to take the moral High ground but
actually Clarkson has done the royal
family a massive favor because he's been
the full guy he's gone out there the
first one to test the water they asked
for an apology he gave it and then they
threw it back in his face
in a vile hate-filled way yes which was
extraordinary when they could have said
thank you very much appreciate this we
all make mistakes move on but that would
have given them the high moral ground
which I think they're incapable of
occupying in reality or in in or even to
fake it they just don't have that bone
in their body at the moment they seem so
narcissistic so vengeful so determined
to create maximum wreckage that even
when somebody is basically saying look
I'm pleased I'm begging you just I'm so
sorry this was terrible it was a moment
of Madness no no you are disgusting
you've been doing this for years we're
gonna finish you too you're on the list
as well and what really troubles me when
you listen to Harry in the audio is the
misogyny in his attitude to women yes
you gave four separate examples and
they're not the only four by the way and
I haven't read the whole book and
frankly I have no intention of
particularly the more I hear about it
and I'm just thinking oh where's where's
his decency yeah where is his equality
between the genders it doesn't seem like
there is any no
no and he thinks he's perfectly
reasonable for him to talk about that
female editor for example he's a good
friend of mine full disclosure
um but to talk about any woman in the
way that he did that whilst presenting
yourself as the enemy of misogyny it's
just breathtaking
it's it's it it's incomprehensible
actually it really is and you just think
what's going on in his head what's going
on in well I think I think I think
there's a lot of anger but I think a lot
of the anger I mean we've seen again the
repercussions are some of the things he
said in this book today you see Iran now
publicly using his boast about killing
25 Taliban naming the kill count
describing him as chess pieces not human
beings you know we saw first of all with
Taliban using that as as a stick to beat
us with now we're seeing Iran and you
don't have to be remotely supportive of
either the Taliban or Iran to understand
the Diplomatic nightmare that Harry has
now caused this country by being so
Brazen in the boasting of killing 25
Taliban you're seeing a Cascade of
unintended consequences reverberating
around the whole world and potentially
he's putting other people's lives at
risk around the world and on it goes and
on it goes and you think I mean if he
had had someone in the UK advise him
edit that book these takes would not
have happened but because he did it all
from the US and he thought he knew
better the consequences I think for the
royal family but for us as a nation and
for UK citizens elsewhere in the world
who have now been put at risk Yeah by
his writings his audios his whole
Behavior his demeanor yeah I completely
agree because it's a short break before
we go to the break I want to play a clip
this is Iman talking about well one of
the two people was Trisha I don't know
whether you've heard this Trisha but
this is what Iman said about you along
with another uh guest I had last week
she said this
I watched you yesterday and the day
before I watched you be gaslit by two
ignorant black women I actually felt
quite sorry for you so I want to say
welcome to the club Piers Morgan how
does it feel to be gaslit when claiming
something is racism how does it feel
it's annoying right it's annoying
well we'll find out how Trisha feels
about that after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
er a tease of all teasers we'll play it
again now just to remind you in case you
missed it
I watched you yesterday and the day
before I watched you be gaslit by two
ignorant black women I actually felt
quite sorry for you so I want to say
welcome to the club Piers Morgan how
does it feel to be gaslit when claiming
something is racism how's it feel it's
annoying right it's annoying
well Trisha here's your chance to
respond this was of course about our
quite fiery debate in which I got very
exercised about the fact that Megan and
Harry for two years led the world to
believe that the palace had been racist
about the skin color of their baby and
then they decided to turn around and say
actually we never meant that at all
which I thought was deplorable you
defended it and that was iman's verdict
on your defense I was basically getting
gaslit what's your response
um not so much the gaslit bit but um I
guess Iman and I would have to agree to
disagree I wouldn't call anybody
ignorant just because they don't agree
with my point of view and I don't think
it's helpful especially when we're
discussing something like racism
um and you know one black person calling
another person black ignorant because
they don't agree that so that that I
find that I find sad I I'm saddened by
that and and you know so I'm not going
to pick a fight with Imam about that
because I've seen that happen uh on you
know I've worked in the media for 35
years I know how that game's played
um so so that would be my only comment
she's entitled to her view you're
entitled to your view I'm entitled to my
view but I think it's I actually think
it's quite disgraceful to label someone
ignorant purely because they don't agree
with you it's not acceptable to call
someone ignorant but you can call them
disgraceful Imam
well no no I said doing it is
disgraceful sorry ignorant
we just heard you you just said she was
disgraceful let her answer me she was
disgraceful okay Iman you're a disgrace
for calling Trisha ignorant I think I'm
awesome personally so I just want to
throw that out there secondly I never
called you uh ignorant because you
didn't agree with my opinion I called
you ignorant because you have a lack of
knowledge there's a clear difference and
it was never about a view it's about
just understanding facts and when we
talk about unconscious bias that's based
on feeling that is a fact Trisha so it's
not about me and you disagreeing as two
black women I'm going to call you
ignorant in spite of your color if you
have a lack of knowledge simple as that
oh thank you so much you're welcome well
Trisha come on you've got to answer the
charge it was basically your ignorance
in lack of knowledge is the subject you
were talking about
if somebody decides that I'm ignorant
I'm not going to sit here and try to to
dissuade them otherwise they've quite
clearly made up their minds if Imam
wants to call me ignorant and thinks of
me and they're ignorant what have you
yeah fine go ahead because she did a lot
of damage that day you did a lot of
damage and I had to come along and fix
it just like Harry did a lot of damage
and other people have to come along and
fix it me Shola chiande we had to come
along and fix your dirty works you know
what I don't have time for people like
you when you come on national TV spewing
garbage and you're right I'll actually
add to your second point I don't want to
argue because I'm a bit more in fact I
don't believe black women should come
onto TV arguing so I'll just leave it at
that I called you ignorant because of
your lack of knowledge
that kind of ends there basically I mean
Trisha what I would say as the token
white man in this debate is I would say
this about what happened last week I was
surprised actually that you with all
your experience of broadcasting and
journalism you're a smart person
that even you when you heard Harry
basically gaslighting the World by
saying we never it was the media that
said that this was racism we didn't say
that and then you literally watch back
exactly what they said to Oprah Winfrey
and they were blatantly accusing a
senior member of the royal family of
being racist about their unborn child
skin color I was surprised that you
couldn't find it in yourself
notwithstanding your support for them
but as a black woman to understand the
damage that that did in playing the race
card as strong as it did to Oprah
Winfrey and then expecting two years
later we would all just sit back when
they go we didn't mean it as racism and
we'd all go oh oh that's all right then
after two years
headlines around the world calling the
royal family races because they had
called them races
I have to actually with that agree with
Richard Tice my colleague Richard Tice
in saying that when Richard you were
right in if it hadn't been Oprah Winfrey
if it had been a British interviewer I
think a British interviewer would have
challenged them on that and got them
actually to say the words my whole thing
was that they didn't as as Susanna uh
your old colleague agreed they didn't
actually say the words and the reason
they didn't I don't think is because
they'd actually said the sentence they
probably would have been sued or God
knows what so my whole argument was they
didn't actually say the words
the key line to me the key line in that
whole thing with Oprah was when Oprah
did actually follow up with one and said
are you saying that the concern was that
if the baby's skin color was too Brown
too dark that would be a problem and she
said yes basically you may well think
that that assumption that was a direct
charge of racism I I I would have I
would have pushed it further I would
actually say I would have actually asked
a question are you saying that somebody
in the royal family is racist I don't
know look I agree and I would have done
but actually Richard ties putting aside
all the what side you're on of this
debate look there are lots of people who
don't agree with me I get it but on that
I did feel completely incense for the
royal family for two years they had to
put up with this charge of racism
against all of them because we never got
told who it was but supposedly expressed
this concern and when you watch back
that exchange with Oprah it was
unequivocal yeah when you watched it
back she specifically said that it would
be a problem if the baby's skin color
was too dark yes was the basic answer no
one had any doubts and there hadn't been
any doubt all over the world for two
years until Harry's interview and they
won the conflict series they never
corrected it and and so everyone's left
completely gobsmacked and you're sort of
wondering what's Harry's objective here
the agenda has changed
yeah so the that's the that's the point
so did he find him no one word about
this in the book no no exactly it's as
though he thought I've gone too far here
right I need to I need to somehow find a
way to row back or let's just give a
distraction and go down another route
there's so many inconsistencies in all
of us
I think it was very damaging you know if
I represented a group like black lives
matter for example and I'd be working
really hard to try and drag
people with you know racist
um undertones about them into a world
where they're not racist because you
explain what racism is to have a member
of the royal family and his wife on two
of them on global television
branding the royal family racist and
then basically saying that's not what we
meant I get why that would incense you
it would incense me I thought it was
absolutely disgusting and that's why I
apologies for cutting you earlier I just
had to make this point about the agenda
changing I just want us to look at their
Journey for a moment we watch them
expose their truth we like their truth
um you see I've changing right expose
their truth defend themselves and now
they are on stage three which is about
making amends and so therefore each
agenda requires a different approach and
so from another strategic standpoint if
you take off the most damning claim of
them or which is the racism Claim by far
the reason why is because you have to
remember it connects to the royal family
potentially paying reparations and you
don't even want to think about what that
number would potentially but I would
also I would also add the other main
charge which I felt was incredibly
damaging was this allegation direct
allegation that Meghan Markle felt
suicidal and had gone to somebody at the
palace seeking help and had been told
she couldn't get it because it would be
basically damaging for the brand again
not a word of that in the book that's
just disappeared like that never
happened we never got told who that
Palace employee was for all we know that
might they might still be working there
did they say that did they look at a
woman saying I'm suicidal and say you
can't get help I didn't believe it at
the time I don't believe it now not a
word in the book and this is again I
think a form of gaslighting on that
issue so you've got race and mental
health or the two sticks to beat the
royal family with both of them now
shattered in terms of any evidence I
will not defend the indefensible I know
that people like Trisha and many others
try I'm not prepared to do it once I
realize you're a liar a liar I will
defend what I believe in but once you
have crossed that line you've crossed
that line and that's a really good
example of the contradictions I hate to
point out contradictions I'm a big fan
or was a big fan of both of them but
even the whole therapy thing I mean I
could sit here and defend you know for
very long lengths of time sitting
conversations defending them but the
reality is they've contradicted to
themselves they contradict themselves
when it came to the whole
and they have lied on a global stage
repeatedly and caused enormous damage
and I said this two years ago nothing
has changed my mind in fact if anything
the disingenuousness of the race charge
being removed the mental health stuff
just disappearing and not being
mentioned again has all just confirmed
to me I was right all along I mean it's
been concreted in stone this lying these
inconsistences and you sort of wonder
where does it go from here the only
upside is that Clarkson's done the royal
family a favor yeah and I agree with
that point they have to maintain the
moral High Ground say nothing do nothing
send an invitation but make sure through
the back door they understand they're
not to come well we're going to move on
to an extraordinary interview after the
break this is where the young man who
was 18 years old when a woman fantasies
an evil woman fantasist invented a
series of rape allegations against him
and against other people and very nearly
got away with having incarcerated for a
very long time he served 10 weeks in
prison it was all a pack of lies and
he's here to tell his story and it is
shocking so this is what lies can do
actually for somebody's life and we'll
talk to him after the break thank you to
Mom to Richard you're going to come back
later on and thanks to Tricia in the
states I appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to Piers Morgan
uncension well my next guest story is as
horrifying as it's astounding
in early 2019 at the age of just 18
Jordan trengrove agreed to go on a date
with a woman called Eleanor Williams
that fateful decision was to change his
life irrevocably Landing him 10 weeks on
the sex offender's wing of a prison
making him a target of a violent
anti-grooming movement
this woman accused him of drugging and
raping her repeatedly she even
fabricated social media posts to prove
it turned out she'd actually attacked
herself
she's since been unmasked as a fantasist
and a Serial liar that claims about
being groomed by an Asian gang spot
far-right protest in her hometown
innocent men face death threats for her
baseless allegations this month she was
found guilty of eight counts and
perverted the course of justice and
three of those related to my guest
Jordan
well Jordan and his girlfriend Kayla
join me now so Jordan
um you haven't done television you two I
know this is new tune you're nervous
about this so let's just go through this
I think methodically you went out on a
on a night out with this woman you knew
her a little bit but not really no I
knew that she worked in a nightclub
um which she was wanting someone to go
out with and I was already out with two
friends and she asked if she could come
with us because she always had no one to
go out with and what happened that night
uh we met all well all of us met up I
was already with my two friends then we
met up with Ellie and basically we went
to a pub called a rebar
um my friend got punched and he was
bleeding so I took him back to his house
in a taxi with his friend and I was
staying at his that night so I had to go
get the keys so we stopped at a cash
machine and took a 10 pound out and went
back to his house and after that I went
back to town to look for Ellie and she
wasn't to be seen anywhere so I went to
where she worked in one of the night
clubs Manhattans and
that's when I was told she was throwing
up on the stairs and I just thought
she's had a bit too much to drink I'll
go carry on with my night out because
they told me they were taking her home
and I carried on with my night out um I
got to a taxi rank at the end of the
night and
a policeman came to get me because I was
drunk and disorderly and they took me
home with another female
um and that was it and for about a week
please drop you home you had too much to
drink
and you gotta take it home and then you
wake up in the morning what happens
it was about a week later that I got
arrested
um and when I got arrested I was asleep
at the time like the police woke me up
and I was thinking what's going on
and it was just weird how it all what
did they say you you don't and I was
arrested for rape and abh the first time
and then about two days later after they
arrested me for that one I was arrested
two days later again
um for another rape in abh and then I
was released on Billboard for them times
um with like conditions not to contact
Ellie go near a property and just to be
clear you did I absolutely no dealing
physically with it at all no no of any
kind nothing at all
um that she said in trial that
apparently kissed her but I didn't even
kiss her that night like not even I
didn't think I'd kissed anyone that
night apart from the person who I went
home with and
it just all destroyed my life what
happened then so you you you then the
police are investigating these three
allegations from this woman about you
and then what happens
um I was arrested another time uh and
that's when I was kept in for like four
days and they told me I was being
charged with it all and that's when
reality hit me like what is going on
like and she produced pictures of
herself all smashed up yes which it
turned out she had done to herself she
said that I beat her up with a shower
head smashed her head off the toilet
drugged her the paramedics when the
founder even thought she was dead it was
to that extent like and she done Mr
herself yeah she's looking at the
pictures now this is all self-inflicted
Yeah by a complete fantasist yeah and
she wasn't just accusing you I think
she's accusing a lot of other people of
other stuff as well but for you you're
18 years old you've done nothing to this
woman and suddenly you're faced with
multiple rape and assault charges what
are you thinking I was disgusted like I
didn't know what was going on and I just
felt horrified I was scared I didn't
know and then when I found out I was
being sent to prison I said to my mom
I'm not going to be coming out alive
because I don't want to go to prison for
if even if I did do something
so why do I want to go if I'm not doing
something wrong you were put on the sex
offender's wing of Preston prison yeah
and you had to share a room with a
pedophile yeah and he told me he pleaded
guilty to that offense what was the
offense he sent pictures to an
eight-year-old kid what did you feel
about having to share a cell or
something like that
I felt sick like physically sick like
and you were there because the police
had concluded you must be guilty of
similar Behavior yeah and I applied for
Bell numerous times my legal team
applied from Bell like I think like four
times and I was denied it every single
time and then I just got woke up one
morning by the police the prison staff
and they said you're in court and I was
confused because I didn't have any
notice beforehand and that's when I went
to court and I got out on bail but I
wasn't allowed to go back to my hometown
I had to sign on the police station
every two days and people in your
hometown thought you were a rapist yeah
I was named in the paper what did they
do
I had Ripper spray painted on my house I
had my windows smashed my mum had to
move out of a house because of it all it
and you spent 10 weeks in prison
yourself yeah so this is going on you're
completely innocent yeah meanwhile
everybody knows you you're on the front
page of the paper you've been named your
family's name has been completely
decimated by this but your accuser who's
made it all up she remained Anonymous
yeah and this is one thing what really
confuses me why did I get named like but
when she was reminded in the prison
there was never an article but she was
charged with this that and the other
well there was but there was no name
given it was just a female
and that's one thing I question a lot
even when she was charged yeah even when
she was charged it was just a female had
been charged with these offenses putting
the paper non-name obviously people knew
who it was because of a Facebook post do
you think it's just completely unfair
the way this is yeah I think it's
completely you'll always have this
attached to you yeah this I had solidala
by the way I was in the back of a
policeman on one of the nights and it
took the police nearly 12 weeks to get
hold of that I mean the police have not
accepted you had nothing to do with it
right with any of this
um but it doesn't change what's happened
to you how's it affected you as a man do
you think it's affected me mentally
physically I don't like leaving the
house I don't like going out I don't
have friends anymore it's I didn't want
a relationship with my son when he was
first born just because I didn't want
him being branded as a rapist son it was
just horrible how it was let me bring in
um your girlfriend Kayla Kayla you you
have a young boy together he's a year
and a half and he's doing great he told
me which is great to hear but you
actually started that you you knew each
other before but you started dating
actually after he came out of prison so
clearly you knew this was all complete
nonsense what he was going through what
did you feel about the way he'd be
treated
I wasn't sure at the start but
um after speaking with a friend and her
making it clear that he was innocent
given the benefit of a doubt and after
reading through paperwork and paperwork
and paperwork
I felt awful and I knew from then that I
had to stick by him and help
what do you think about the law as it
stands where Jordan gets named and
shamed and will always have to live with
that you Google your name it'll always
come up now with rape alongside it and
that's the horrific nature of what
you've had to go through which will
always be there but his accuser until
she actually got convicted last week of
just inventing all this against a number
of men and ruining so many lives and she
remained Anonymous for a large part of
that process yeah I said to Jordan at
the start that
he should never have been named and
like I I just think until you've been
found guilty you shouldn't be named and
it it's caused a big problem and mud
sticks and he's got that forever now and
at one stage I mean you even considered
taking your own life yeah I took an
overdose in front of my own mum it was
that badly my mum's best friend killed
herself two days before I tried doing
that and my emotions towards my mum were
just empty I didn't like think of what
her best friend did and I went and did
the same in front of my mom and I didn't
think of anything I didn't ever put
other people's feelings first if you get
what I mean because
my life was just too messed up with all
this stuff has it got any easier for you
Jordan since the verdict I've been
leaving the house a little bit more do
local people now will realize that
you've been completely framed I have my
next door neighbor believes Ellie and
she has for a long time well next door
neighbor believes the accuser yeah even
though she's now being convicted yeah
she's always she's had complaints into
our Housing Association that I'm the
rapist this nervous if you're pulling
but that's the impact of this right yeah
my landlord came around the house and
questioned Kayla on Iran in front of the
children why have you not told me
Jordan's been a convicted rapist and
obviously I wasn't convicted I was only
on remand but it was just the fact that
he couldn't ask me before we moved in
when I told him I've been to prison he
didn't ask what for and stuff like that
right and then he just he judged yeah
and he's just since then people have
been putting in them complaints he's
just
changed in a completely different person
towards how important has Kayla been to
you she's been amazing like she's been
my absolute Rock for it all she's like
you'd even be here without her no I say
it to her all the time if it wasn't for
Kayla I really do think I'd be that now
because them allegations just ruined my
life
I mean that's so sad to hear isn't it
Kayla I mean an amazing thing that
you've done for Jordan I've been there
for him in his darkest time but he
should never have been through all this
and I think it is a really interesting
debate you know the the crown prosecutor
Wendy Lloyd said the false accusation of
his kind of very rare that is true this
has been an unusual case it's important
for victims of rape or sexual assault to
understand that they should never fear
coming forward to report the crown of
police or we can all agree with that the
issue is whether people should remain
anonymous on one side the accusers
but the people being accused get named
and shamed even if as in your case you
were completely innocent and that is the
debate that has to be had I think the
police would argue well they name people
uh who are accused of rape because they
often find that it triggers a number of
other complaints about that person
and the the other argument about not
naming the accuser who's normally a
woman is that it would deter women from
coming forward if they got name I can
understand both those arguments but when
I hear your story I I find it completely
disgusting and I'm just so sorry for
what you've been through yeah it was
it's discussing what I've been through
because
I've not only gone through false
accusations I've been filled by the
police and the justice system when there
was solid evidence there that I was in
the back of it but they didn't want to
pursue it because they had it in their
minds they believed it yeah they
basically believed and accuse it this
goes back to my thing you should never
automatically believe anybody who makes
any allegations you should always hear
them take them seriously and investigate
but the danger comes when the
authorities automatically believe
accusers without the evidence to support
it Jordan thank you for coming in I know
you were nervous about doing this and
Kayla thank you for for joining him
you've been an amazing support to him
it's an awful story we're going to
debate it after break without with our
panel but for now I wish you all the
very best in rebuilding your life thank
you very much take care thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome welcome back to Facebook when I
say so this is live TV and we're having
a relatively let me see it's a good show
tonight it's a strong show lots of to
debate we're not having quite the same
show that Gary didn't get is having
tonight over at the BBC because they're
showing the Wolves Liverpool game and
halfway through Gary talking this
happened
with an FA Cup winners only policy in
the studio tonight and I don't know
who's making that noise but so Alan
Sherry is on the commentary Gantry
alongside um Steve Bauer
um Alan
um it's toasty in this studio it's a bit
noisy as well I don't know somebody's
sending something on someone's phone I
think I think it would be fair to
describe that as adult entertainment
creeping into the early schedule over
there Lyrica Tweeter letter we found
this a phone taped to the back of the
set a sabotage goes it was quite amusing
who has done this somebody has
completely stitched them up
um anyway uh it made me laugh it's
making everybody else laugh on social
media so my thoughts with with Gary at
this difficult time
um let's get back to more serious things
uh we joined by Paul Ron Adrian Richard
Tyson still with us any man still with
us from earlier I just want to talk
really just the few minutes we've got
left Paul I'll start with you about what
we've just heard this story
harrowing awful despicable we can all
agree the woman that did this Beyond
despicable really the question though is
what what do we do about this where he
is named and shamed and we'll have to
live with that forever and you'll Google
him and up it comes Jordan rape
she has remained Anonymous right to the
point of her conviction for for
inventing all this stuff should the law
be changed
no it's the short answer to that
question let me explain to you why
number one we've already tried it it's
actually happened where we had a moment
in time uh about 10 or 12 years where
they considered and implemented a change
where defendants were also anonymous
and it didn't work and in 1988 they
changed it back again Why didn't it work
it didn't work because it became we
became bogged down essentially with the
system so if we're not if we're going to
anonymize defendants in rape cases do we
anonymize defendants in other very
equally serious cases and the answer was
simply no we couldn't but the difference
the difference is that the accuser in
rape cases remains Anonymous even if as
it turns out in this case they're
complete fantasies and that Richard is
the particular thing around sex assault
cases and rapes unlike a lot of other
crimes where people can make allegations
but they would be named in many cases
but in many cases it is we do still have
a number of cases where the accuser is
not named so we're also talking about
vulnerable victims we're also talking
about
um victims who have not just making a an
allegation about sexual offense but if
it's a murder charge or no I get it it's
complicated but I think when this all
takes way too long I mean this can take
years and years well that's the whole
process but I hear what you say yes but
I'm aware of another case of a young man
who did remain completely Anonymous for
over 12 months until the trial and it
turned out that it was another pack of
lines so I'm wondering is there an
element of judgment that the CPS or the
police are applying in in different
cases I don't know but it just seems to
me that there has got to be a proper
intelligent assessment I get the point
that you you might want to give the name
because that might uh and it alsoever
does and it often does I mean that's the
point genuine but so there's a so it's
incredibly difficult what you don't want
to do you don't want to deter women I
mean it as it is so few rape cases lead
to conviction yeah a lot of women are
deterred from coming forward for that
reason it is can we not only say women
we're talking about four in five men as
well okay yes we're talking about
children so this is not just about
understand fair point I think just on
the general principle of in-rape cases
specific to this particular interview I
just did should it be the case that
young men 18 years old get named and
shamed as accused rapists ruining their
lives I mean nearly cost him his life
hadn't been for his girlfriend he said
he might be dead by now and yet his
accuser who was an evil fantasist
was Anonymous that whole time I think
it's disgusting and it's backward and it
makes absolutely no sense to me and can
I say that there are laws in place
because remember of course everybody has
the right to a fair trial okay that's
just the basics basic start point and if
for whatever reason the CPS or the
defense are concerned that there isn't
going to be a fair trial then of course
orders can be made that will protect as
in the case of the example that you've
had that will protect the defendant so
it's not the case that it's just surely
when you hear what happened to this
young boy I've got three sons on their
20s there but if one of them have been
through this the whole system failed
this kid that there was a willingness to
believe that accuser and we've seen this
before sometimes with the police where
they don't just listen to an accuser
they believe the accuser we saw that
with that Infamous case of Nick that
fantasy who smeared all sorts of
high-profile people yeah I don't think
you should ever start from a presumption
of belief
the starting point is you've got to have
the highest quality specialized team
assessing the cases day one and looking
at the evidence and saying actually yeah
this this is clearly very likely this
looks a bit dodgy and frankly on this
side I really don't I think look we're
going to leave I'm running out of time
but we have to take it seriously and
look at this case and think are there
things we can tweak here because that
was an appalling storage isn't it thank
you to my panel really appreciate it
that's it for me whatever up to keep it
unsettled they're not as uncensored as
Gary Let It Go we'll run out of time for
my joke
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]